Josh is in Omaha hi Josh how are you I'm
hanging in there how are you do better
than I deserve what's up so I I've been
listening to you for a couple years now
and I was I was in pilot training down
in Texas for the airport's on that
Guardsman hearing in my home state of
Nebraska thank you for your service
yeah it's a no problem I kind of got
that pulled out from under me it was a
25-year dream and I got I got removed
for training from training partially
relating some health issues and and it
was it's kind of a shock it hit me hit
me pretty hard and my I had a whole
long-term goal you know I'm a kind of
guy who who is on a plan and is working
the plan and I was working kind of
working your plan down there with uh
with my wife and my finances being a
little bit separated just because I was
I was away and she was here managing the
homefront and all my extra money was
going in going towards debt but that
wasn't that's not really what I'm
calling to talk about I got that kind of
pulled out from under me and so all my
long-term goals were driving my
short-term goals and everything
everything's kind of gone now I don't
know where to go next everything was
pulled out from under me I'm having
trouble seeing court sort of see in my
path forward and I guess I'm calling ask
you how do you do that how do you how do
you how do you see your life everything
you thought your life is going to be
from you know six months goals two
five-year goals - 20-year goals getting
getting kind of kind of changed you know
one of the things I think that's a myth
about that is that if Mike Tyson walks
up to your life and punches it out and
knocks your life flat of its back for
some reason we all think me included
that you know or I used to think that
you would just you just get right back
up and go you know go do another thing
right and so I used to tell people you
know I you know people used to say how
did you bounce back after your
bankruptcy well I didn't
Mike Tyson knocked my lights out you
know life had any Kayode baby I was on
the mat seeing stars you know I had a
concussion I was bleeding out of every
part of my head you know I mean right
you know so what I did was what I did
was I laid there and cried and blamed
everybody else for a little while which
is a very human thing to do when your
entire life gets Kayode so first let me
give you permission to go this sucks
yeah okay and there's a part of kind of
I don't want you to lay there for ten
years this doesn't need to define your
life but you know four takes longer than
10 minutes to emotionally recover to
having a 10-year goal taken away from
you is that okay to say yet yeah I mean
I'm having I'm having trouble getting up
in the morning I'm having gable down
here my house yeah you know yeah
absolutely because what you were living
for was taken it's gone yeah and it you
know it's normal to have the blues and
if you're not careful you can slip off
into depression even and that's what
happens I mean you hear these guys I
worked this company for 15 years and
they fired me one day and everybody goes
well whoopee get over it you know
well no crap I put 15 years of my
freakin life into that place they just
dumped me with no warning with no I know
a side come of course you're gonna feel
like you got punched in the face you
know I mean so we just need to give each
other permission to be human a little
bit I don't want you to live in this I'm
not saying being become negative Ned I'm
not saying ER is your new spirit animal
that's not what I'm saying okay but I am
I am saying it's okay to hurt because
you've been working on this for a lot of
years and now it's not going to happen
this way now
what you do is you start becoming a
little introspective you go okay what
happened here what was the part I played
in what happened here what were the
things that were out of my control and
what happened here which is called
giving yourself some grace and the other
parts of parts you screwed up is part
you learn from and you start
establishing some no matter what's in
your life no matter what I will never
dot dot dot again right yeah and I did
that around the money piece no matter
what I don't borrow money ever again I'm
done you know no matter what I always
give a tenth of my income to my church
period
and I don't care if you don't like it or
don't agree with it it's not really your
money and so shut up I always do that
you know and you're going to get some no
matter what's from your pain and then
you're going to see that these lemons
can be turned into lemonade and it's
going to start to heal for you it's
going to start to come back together and
you in it and are you going to know what
your new life goal is in the first 20
minutes after you get kod
not unless you're weird it takes a
little healing to be able to see again
through those eyes that both got blacked
I'm using a metaphor here I think you're
catching it okay but hold on I'm going
to give you a book called start and I'm
going to give you a no but another book
called a go-getter and I'm gonna send
them both to use my gift and they're
going to help you turn and I want you to
call me again as you're working your way
through this you're gonna make it dude
you got the right stuff it's just for
something else